as the leftist tears downpour in ters
its sixth day Democrats have embraced
the rain dance
according to left-wing outlet vox.com
modern witches are creating rituals to
foster activism in the wake of Justice
Cavanaugh's confirmation to the Supreme
Court we will analyze Democrats diamond
craft and cultic symbolism more broadly
in politics then Kanye totally kills it
in the Oval Office pc mobs tell us to
stop calling the mobs or else and boxes
Jane Koston joins to discuss civility
finally the mailbag I'm Michael Knowles
and this is the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
oh so much to get to we have way too
much to get to not enough time let's
jump right in and make a little money
honey with the zip recruiter zip recruit
you know them you know zip recruiter
thank goodness if recruiter wasn't
around when I showed up here at the door
a starving out-of-work actor a blank
book author not a penny to my name
unfortunately we didn't have a zip
recruiter then now we have a zip
recruiter so we hire only the most
qualified candidates zip recruiter is
fabulous there are job sites that sends
you to tons of the wrong resumes to sort
through that's not smart there are job
sites that make you wait for the right
candidates to just find you through I
don't know magic that's not smart what
zip recruiter does is you post a job -
zip recruiter it will go out and help
you find the candidates it will send
them over to you that's why zip
recruiter is rated number one by
employers in the u.s. it actively
invites people to apply in this rating
by the way the number one in the u.s.
comes from hiring sites on trust pilot
with over 1000 reviews this is the way
to do it go to zip brooder zip recruiter
com /m K s this is the way to find
qualified candidates right now you can
try it for free at the exclusive web
address pull over your car and write it
down
zip recruiter dot-com /m K s go do it go
right now go I'm waiting zip recruiter
comp slash MKS one more time one more
time for good measure zip recruiter com
/m k s Kanye was in the Oval Office this
morning this was such a what I can't
look I wish I could turn off my show
today and we just watched the Kanye
press or the whole thing and we still
wouldn't have enough time we'd still
have to do another show tomorrow
it is so phenomenally good it is one of
these things you watch it you just I
know some conservatives are still doer
and pessimistic for some reason watching
this and just imagine you today telling
you three years ago that this would be
happening but the biggest pop star in
the world the biggest popular musician
probably on planet Earth
would be wearing a Maggie hat in the
Oval Office talking about how great the
Republican administration is and making
fun of liberals with that language you
wouldn't believe it but it's happening
it's how you know we're living in the
matrice matrix rather with that further
ado Kanye West's take it away and that's
one of the moves that I love that
liberals tried to do the liberal would
try to control a black person through
the concept of racism because they know
that we are very proud of motional
people so when I said I like Trump to
like someone that's liberal they'll say
oh but these races you think races okay
control me it's an invisible what
question we don't go to another question
I answered this question how do you
answer question it's a simple sign
soundbite shoot you are tasting a fine
wine I has multiple don't you do it
you better play 40 chess with me like a
Minority Report oh I'm tasting a fine
wine too mm-hmm that's the fun wine from
MSNBC in the media melting down and I
love it by the way these guys remember
Kanye West said he and Trump have dragon
energy they're like they really do they
do share something together watching
them sit across from each other in the
Oval Office it's like seeing double if I
were a lefty and I went in there I
wanted to go get Donald Trump I wouldn't
know which one to shoot I'd say oh no
which is the real Trump I again they're
they're like such similar people and
they have such the same approach when
you go out there and you say you try to
shame them you try to get them to change
their mind you try to get them to stop
saying what they want to say they just
flat-out say no they'll double down on
what they're saying you know Kanye West
said you think that by using the word
racist you can control my actions use it
well ain't gonna happen I was talking
last week about how rapists is the new
racist it's just the way that the left
tries to control you and pressure you
into cow telling to their will it used
to be they call perfectly good people
racists with no evidence now they're
calling them rapists with no evidence
and some squishy conservatives they say
oh no I don't want them I oh I don't
want MSNBC to call me something bad no
no Donald Trump he don't care Kanye West
he don't care they're sitting there in
this room arms crossed come at me
so beautiful he got so much pushback
what did he do he tightened his mag a
cap on his head and he stir he's going
out there saying you know what liberals
do like he's doing a stand-up routine
absolutely beautiful stuff by the way
he's there on the day of signing the
the MMA the what is the I forget the
actual title of a music Modernization
Act it is which is a very important
piece of legislation by the way that's
good that he's here for that as well and
only this administration could have
gotten that through with the Republican
Congress and Senate we'll get to that in
a second but he's there just fielding
questions
he cannot be pressured he cannot be
forced to say some view that he doesn't
hold MSNBC CNN the mainstream media they
are furious about that
open up your tumblers and let the good
times roll I'm doing this for everybody
who's watching us who turned their
volume down you can put it back up again
that what if you think you're going to
get a sawed filet by play and political
analysis you're not because that was an
assault on our white house we're not
we're not
we can't analyze some of that stuff that
was said as we warned you at the top
there was a little profanity we there
was actually more than you heard we were
able to bleep some of it out but there
was some of it didn't make it in there
that was crazy that was longer all of a
sudden now the left there they're
clutching their pearls about profanity
they hate profanity these are people the
left airs PSAs of little children
screaming the f-word scream all of these
things they have [ __ ] walks every every
big sign that they post is F this and F
Trump and F that that's all they were t
he he they all giggle now they clutch
their pearls he said Kanye West might
have said a swear word in the Oval
Office just Google Lyndon Johnson
cussing Lyndon Johnson cursed listen to
what Lyndon Johnson said in the Oval
Office I'll tell you his language was a
lot saltier than Kanye West's how about
Bill Clinton what did so we're talking
about when Kanye West said in the Oval
Office let's only think back on people
degrading the Oval Office what did Bill
Clinton do in the Oval Office you know
you know how I'm you know I like cigars
for instance I'm a cigar fan a cigar
enthusiast and they say sometimes a
cigar is just a cigar well for mr.
Clinton sometimes a cigar is not just a
cigar and sometimes it's not just a
cigar in the freakin Oval Office you
hacks you hypocrites open up the
tumblers Kahn is in what they're really
a
set about is that it's not just a racial
thing though there is a racial component
they're upset that a prominent black man
is now a Republican is supporting a
Republican administration they're also
upset that a celebrity is supporting a
Republican
they're also upset that a young person
is supporting Republic they're also
upset that a musician is support it's a
perfect storm and they are all they're
all Alyssa Milano's they're all these
little kind of doughy white people
Alyssa Milano's not doughy but she is
her intellect is at least a little
bloated and she's and they say make
Kanye Kanye again Kanye he's not allowed
to say these things he's in what does he
do he tightens that Magga cap even
tighter
absolutely beautiful stuff well we're
gonna have to talk about this with Jane
coast and when she comes on cuz the left
is furious the narrative is breaking
down what MSNBC is saying they said you
probably had your your TV on mute no no
no you had your TV on mute MSNBC we were
all watching and you wish we had our TV
on mute they're saying no there until
the Wizard of Oz no no don't don't look
over don't look at the man behind the
curtain
no no don't believe you're a lion eyes
sorry I saw it I saw it love it we've
got a we've got to move on unfortunately
because there's so much to get to
they're actually the Democrats are now
admitting that they're practicing
witchcraft yeah I like the voice of one
crying out in the wilderness right now I
was calling this last week another admit
yeah we practice witchcraft before we
get to that I've got to thank bamboo HR
let's make a little more money honey I
know this you know it I'm trying to make
this day even better you've got Kanye
becoming a huge Republican you've got
Democrats admitting that they're witches
and now I just want a little money to
make it perfect and I can help you make
some money because bamboo HR manages all
of your employee data and automates the
countless tasks you have to deal with if
you own a small or medium-sized business
if you work in HR you know how crazy it
can be look you can imagine working with
me HR is a top concern for people and so
oh I'm sorry my phone is ringing I know
the real I'm sorry this is why we need
HR is because of accidents like this we
we got to call up our HR manager
if you work in HR if you work with me
you need a lot of HR it's very important
and people don't want to deal with it
they don't want to deal with the
spreadsheets the time off to manage
things that never-ending paperwork the
countless random employee issues the
stress is huge let bamboo HR make it
easy
it's totally intuitive no long-term
contracts or commitments right now
bamboo HR is giving my listeners a
special extended free trial instead of
their standard 7-day trial you can try
out bamboo HR for a full 14 days bamboo
HR dot-com / cough FAC o VF e fe for
this exclusive extended free trial
bamboo HR com / cough fa Co V Fe Fe
limited time offer only available now do
it quickly before you get sued or
something you know because you've got an
employee like me who one of the best
things I do is leave the telephone on
bamboo HR calm / go facio v fe fe bamboo
HR calm / co FF a before we bring on
Jane I have to read you this article
from box that's actually from Jane's
publication Jane Koston I will say
something nice about her she is
certainly the most reasonable person at
fox comm that's why we talk that's why
I'm having her on the show and actually
I read Vox all the time because it
presents honestly the left-wing point of
view and their being really really
honest today they have this this piece
out we refuse to be silent any longer
magic as self-care after Cavanaugh and I
actually managed to infiltrate a recent
Democrat
strategy meeting I got to go down there
I got to bring a camera and I got to see
firsthand how the Democrats are
retooling your strategy through the
midterms by the pricking of my thumb's
Something Wicked This Way Comes
togas under cold stone days and nights
at 31 where children are sleeping got
boil thou first in the Talmud a liver of
blaspheming you all of the transcripts
of you come to you fight that's what you
profess howe'er you come to know it
answer me to what I asked you
answer me Diane Feinstein that last one
was Dianne Feinstein there if you
couldn't see it was I think his shot was
mostly from the back of her head but
that was Dianne Feinstein so this is how
the article goes quote modern-day
witches are creating rituals to foster
solidarity activism and healing it goes
on first take a candle then pour some
salt into your hand then keeping the
grains in your palm take a pen to write
out a thank you to christine Blasi ford
the woman whose allegations
uncorroborated evidence-free frequently
contradicted and refuted allegations of
sexual assault against Supreme Court
nominee and now justice Brett Kavanaugh
stunned a nation or if you prefer simply
say I believe you it's just one of the
many quasi religious rituals circulating
the internet particularly pagan and
hashtag resistance circles I love that
they can flake those two you know the
pagan and the resistance circles every
similar in the wake of Cavanaugh's
confirmation these rituals help
self-identified witches process trauma
anger and grief now I will tell you
something I have always appreciated the
political philosophical you of Exodus 20
to 18 now shalt not suffer a witch to
live I have long appreciated that and I
told you this I we were talking about
this just a couple days ago leftism can
rise to the level of religion and these
days it really seems to have risen to
the level of religion and not good
religion you know I will point out
because they go this thing goes on and
on they people describing the rituals as
a vital spiritual solidarity and and it
also goes on to talk about the 20% of
Americans who identify as spiritual but
not religious for whom rituals can
provide a framework for finding meaning
in trauma or pain you know I talk often
about spiritual but not religious it is
just fertile ground for this kind of
religion everybody's got to serve
somebody
for the atheists who are watching
conservative atheists conservative
agnostics I just want to point out a
theist always atheists always get this
wrong in agnostics I think kind of
missed the point here too which is when
they say oh it's so silly religion is so
silly
oh it's so it's so ridiculous it's
superstition some some things can be
superstition but religion in here's in
every human society throughout all of
history since the dawn of time perhaps
that tells us something about the human
condition
perhaps that tells us something not just
about our own condition and our own
longings but the satisfaction of our
longings which exists in the
metaphysical in the spiritual world
perhaps it tells us that because
everybody's got to serve somebody you
know the the piece goes on it says
describing their meditation and
ritualistic process yoga teacher Laura
Kelleher told Vox as a non-binary gender
fluid person I'm focusing on integrating
my own feminine and masculine aspects
and moreover the abusive and abused
parts of my psyche okay but by the way
this means Matt Walsh was right - they
said that Yoga is just paganism and
Satanism it's it is is witchcraft you
know a mayor Bolshevik Bolshevik Bill
DeBlasio in New York he signed a bill
today saying that there's now a third
gender on birth certificates male/female
into X that's witchcraft that's hocus
pocus that is superstition there are two
sexes we know that there are two sexes
and there are there is there are men
there are women there are men who think
that they're women there are women who
think that they're men and there was a
small number of people for whom their
sex is a little ambiguous they might
have an extra X chromosome they might
have ambiguous genitalia abside toda
that's a real thing of course that's a
real thing but that's not a third gender
that's a combination of - that's the
idea that there is some third sex or
gender that is a fiction that is
witchcraft the Emmis religion of leftism
gets worse and worse we'll before I
bring Jane on I just I have to show you
this remember that guy the one who
kicked the pro-life woman at that rally
he they're called nuns YouTube they're
calling him Chuck Norris be kissy you
know Chuck Norris would roundhouse kick
people and this guy is you know not the
manliest
man so they're calling him Chuck Norris
anyway you might remember him 16 year
old it's a baby if someone is raped and
she gave birth and she decided to kill
her three-year-old child so did you say
if you I didn't notice this the first
couple times he's wearing a pentagram on
his neck he's wearing the sign of Satan
on his neck that's no coincidence
do we think that's really what now you
might say oh it's just a sign that he
likes you know what it's a very specific
sign oh it's no big deal well if it's no
big deal why is he wearing it and why
are all of these hysterical mobs focused
around one thing the fictitious
constitutional right to kill a baby you
notice this guy kicks this woman because
she was at a pro-life rally all of the
Cavanaugh hullabaloo all of the
witchcraft that Fox is talking about in
the wake of Cavanaugh is about the
fictitious constitutional right to kill
an unborn baby
it's about Roe versus Wade maybe that's
not a coincidence
maybe that's because ideas do have
consequences little decisions little in
decisions have major consequences if you
if you trace bad ideas back far enough
you get to the devil that's it you know
you got to go back pretty far for some
of them but you do get to the lies you
get to the father of lies and that
occultic aspect is hard to ignore you
have to almost willfully ignore it but I
do I really appreciate Vox this is why I
read Vox all the time because they do
provide very honest perspectives for
honest left-wing perspectives that
you're not going to get anywhere else
and the best person at Vox you all know
the best person who box is Jane Koston
who I have on now Jane do we have you we
do how are you Jane thank you for coming
on I appreciate it I was recent I was
just going through did you see that
article on Vox today about the
witchcraft in the wake of Brett
Kavanaugh I did I did that was from Tara
Burton who writes a lot about religion
it's interesting because I think that a
lot of her work works on she talked a
lot about the Vatican and the recent
crisis in the Catholic Church and I
think it's particularly challenging
because when we talk about religion here
we're talking about
of different religions so I think it's
interesting that she's able to write so
effectively across a wide swath oh yeah
I really like the piece I think people
should go read it I liked another there
was one in ality a while ago on on the
cultic imagery in that ariana grande
video and it was this terrific piece
written by a self-described witch and I
think a lot of people on the left and
the right don't they don't appreciate
religious symbolism because a lot of
people are religiously illiterate now
you are not religiously illiterate and
you have you have some common ground
with conservatives or you at least have
an understanding of some aspects of
conservatism which i think makes you
unique in many ways
so I want your perspective on this
completely changing gears here Hillary
Clinton within the last couple days has
said that the time for civility is over
we can't be civil we're going to be
civil once the Democrats retake the
government Eric Holder said forget about
Michelle Obama's when they go low we go
high when they go low we're gonna kick
them right in the face
what say you both the perspective on
civility from the left and broadly for
the whole country well I think from the
left we have to recognize that the left
is responding to this phenomenon at
which the right has basically been
saying why are you kicking yourself why
are you kicking yourself while you're
picking yourself for three years and no
do you think the White has been uncivil
I think the right has been uncivil yes I
think everyone involved has been uncivil
and I'm operating entirely in good faith
here I think that the same people you
know I think that it's complicated and I
talk about this a lot how when we talk
about the right or the left we need to
be really careful in our terms because I
think that we run the risk of conflating
David French at National Review with
someone writing at Breitbart when we
boat we all know that those are not the
same thing different potasium right
different perspectives there's you know
we're not talking about noah rothman at
commentary versus like someone getting
aggregated at twitchy
these are different things in a
different conceptualization of what the
right is so I think that first and
foremost it's important to kind of get
at our terms here because I think what
Clinton and Holder and others are
responding to is this idea that you know
I remember that that was that kind of
meme of 2015 2016 about Trump the but he
fights that you know Trump accusing Ted
Cruz's father of being the killer of JFK
was just raising questions he was just
raising you just raise a question you
know nothing happened to him and you saw
again and again that you know everyone
made fun of Jeb Bush because basic you
know called him a kook because he wasn't
like Trump and this idea that Trump won
on the basis of fighting and on the
basis of just feeling willing to insult
people and insulting Ted Cruz's wife and
insulting Hillary Clinton and this idea
that okay
well that seemed to work and now you're
seeing I think some people on the Left
say like all right well I mean I think
that that's what you're kind of but
Michael I Benetti is a logical
presidential candidate because he's just
as terrible right right but you know and
I totally grant you Donald Trump fought
very hard against his Republican primary
opponents and against Hillary Clinton
but you remember Hillary Clinton called
half the country deplorable and
irredeemable
and this wasn't and and I'm not even
that concerned about political rhetoric
per se because both sides can get nasty
both sides can fight what I'm talking
about though is since President Trump
won
you've got elected Democrats Maxine
Waters say go out there find Republicans
where they eat where they sleep go to
their homes
you know harass them in public I don't
think that we have seen a similarity on
the right eye I actually don't think
that there's moral equivalence here I
think that it's challenging because
again we're working with our definitions
of like who gets to be counted on the
right because I know that if I bring up
unite the right and Charlotte's bill you
will rightly say like those aren't
conservatives yell Richard Spencer they
say that they're not conservatives they
say that they're alternative IMed and
then you'll see like David Duke when he
was that unite the right was like I'm
here because of Donald Trump and
understandably conservatives would be
aquo that's no that's not on us that's
not a part of us but those guys join
there's a difference between David Duke
and Richard Spencer and the you know now
I think what has atrophied to the five
people in their basements who call
themselves alternative right down from
200 or 300 to Maxine Waters who was an
elected Democrat who's been in office
forever
yeah and Steve King is also an elected
Republican and again like we could keep
going back and forth and I think that if
Kings never called for violence never
called for public harassment I think
that when you're talking about someone
like Steve King or you're talking about
this concept of like who's promoting
violence and who isn't promoting
violence I think that it's important
first I want to say at the top that
promoting violence is bad it's a bad
idea someone like drives into a building
because they insist I think I just want
to be here on the record saying please
don't drive into a building but I want
to be cleared that there is a sense that
I think a lot of people not have this
idea that you know when there's a lock
her up chance at a rally which obviously
beaches not violence to be perfectly
clear but I think there's a sense like
why can these people get away with
something and we can't get away with
something when no one should be getting
away with it but the locker the locker
up chant is asking why Hillary Clinton
is allowed to get away with something as
well right which is why is she allowed
to get away with mishandling federal
records why she lied to get away with
wiping her server's why she lied to get
away with this and that I'm not I'm not
defending it though I do defend the
locker up chin I'm just saying there is
a difference between that and saying go
go to Hillary Clinton's home where she
sleeps and kick her out of restaurants I
think that there is a sense that there
is no how best to put this I think that
for some people on the left there is a
sense that the degradation of how people
see politics and the personalization of
politics means that they're an idea that
yo if you see Ted Cruz that's the same
Ted Cruz who is you know making fun of
Boehner o'rourke for pointing up the the
murder of bossom jean and a twitter ad
you know that the personalization of
politics means that people yo you you
see Ted Cruz you're not
seeing Ted Cruz guy eating didn't you're
seeing Ted Cruz that politician and I
think that there is a sense on the left
and I think somewhat on the right in a
little bit but it's a third I think it's
a different conceptualization that the
personalization of politics means that
political figures it's not you know a
lot of people have criticized this
because you see pictures of Michelle
Obama and George W Bush together and
they've talked a lot about how they have
this really enjoyable friendship and
people get very mad about this I'm going
to write on the left because there's
that you know that old 5vs5 thing that
everyone kind of clocks in we yell at
each other we clock out we go back to
hang again which in some ways is
actually kind of how it should work a
little bit but for a lot of people on
both sides there's a sense like no no we
this is a fight that you know you see
people who would start longing for the
return of the Civil War which no one
should long for the return of the Civil
War you see things like well the red
states have more guns or like well we do
have more guys I mean there's no
question about that I think that yo won
the Civil War was bad and we should do
it again but also the purchased means
that you know people when someone is
sending Maxine Waters or someone sending
Cory Gardner death threats you're not
sending a person death threats you're
sending this political entity who's not
a real person
well I would I think of it i I do want
to point out on the personalization of
politics though is I agree with you
entirely I despise the personalization
of politics I will point out just as an
historical point it was the new left
that adopted this mantra in the 1960s
the personal is the political the
political is the personal there were the
second wave feminists but much more
broadly than second wave feminists and I
don't know I think you're seeing the
fruit of that today it but I do want to
know also because when I look at the you
know where the Democratic Party is going
I I don't know I have my own skewed
perspective you know I don't think I've
referred to Elizabeth Warren without
calling her liya Wafaa in the last two
years so I want to know from your
perspective where do you think it's
gonna go or is it going to be some
belligerent Michael avenatti you know
guy who just makes things up and
challenges people to mix
martial arts fights or are you going to
get a more I don't know I actually don't
even really know who them who are the
moderate or centrist Democrat would be I
guess Joe Biden would be maybe the
closest where is it going to go and as
we headed through them in terms and into
2020 well I think that it's complicated
because you know if we think back to
2014 people were not exactly talking
about a Donald Trump presidential run
until we get to do that you know the
June 2015 excavator moment right but I
think that what you're seeing on the
ground right now is that the number one
issue that Democrats are running on
isn't Trump it's not Russia it's
healthcare and you're seeing that in
state after state after state after
state and you know I'll talk
specifically about say the state of
Michigan state of Michigan is a really
interesting example because you have the
Democrats going really hard on the issue
of criminal justice because they're
pointing out the fact that Larry Nasser
one of the worst sexual abusers in
American history right who abuse
hundreds of children essentially you
know a lot of Democrats are kind of
saying like clearly Republicans who are
in charge and Lansing we're not able to
get a handle on this issue or on the
Flint water issue so I think what you're
going to see more is it's increased you
know I think interpreters will love it
because it's a return to federalism
increase the Localism in politics
because you're seeing yo in Ohio in
Wisconsin in Minnesota in Michigan a lot
of these states you're seeing people
saying you know I don't really can't you
know Trump Russia whatever that's fun I
want to talk about this specific issue
you saw that in Virginia last year in
the special election where you had
candidates who were running for the
Virginia House talking about like I have
nothing to say about Trump all I care
about is this traffic issue and they win
because it turns out that when you live
in the state of Virginia you care a lot
about traffic and so I'm I'm not sure
what that's going to result in in terms
of a 20/20 nominee because I have gotten
out of the business of trying to predict
what's going to happen
residential nominees but I do think that
Democrats on the ground are really going
with it okay what are people actually
worried about not like I think that
there's a sense that you know there's
like what we get riled up about on
Twitter there are people who are
fake worried about things and then there
are people you know I think you know
when I was before I came to Vox you know
I was paying for my own and my spouse's
own health care and that was a that's a
major concern for millions of people I
was really concerned about housing
issues because you know I live in the
city of DC he's very expensive for
housing and it kind of in yo when we
decide to have a family that's something
we need to think about and it is for a
lot of people which is why you're seeing
housing becoming a big electoral issue I
think in ya know and elsewhere well I do
I do i I think I think you're absolutely
right especially in the Twitter point
which is that a twitter is largely fake
you know it is all of the outrage well I
think that is largely fake when it gets
down to real people I'm skeptical that
we're gonna be returning to federalism I
I hope you're right I think it would be
very nice if we do that but I think that
we're thoroughly in the bread and
circuses politics as entertainment
presidential politics is entertainment
mode so but we'll have to see I have to
let you go Jane thank you for being here
we will have to have you back all right
see you later so we have to get to
mailbag before we do that I do want to
mention very briefly the music
modernization act the music
modernization act it nobody is talking
about this nobody knows what it means I
think conservatives are a little
misguided on this that is what President
Trump signed into law today all the
musicians were at the White House you
passed
I think unanimously is it pet through
Congress in the Senate as the first bill
to do that it maybe in my lifetime you
know I don't remember and certainly in
this political climate what what the
music Modernization Act does is it
really helps out songwriters so it just
briefly because I think some people
think that it's the government intruding
into the market with regard to music and
music publishing and streaming it's
exactly the opposite the government has
had its heavy hand on this for so long
and I know a number of songwriters
pretty pretty well-known songwriters so
they've they've been looking into this
for years and years apparently then what
happened is in 1906 or 1907
no roll companies you know like the
player pianos you put the roll in and
it's just starts playing good they were
really upset because they didn't want to
have to pay songwriters so they go to
Papa
Uncle Sam big government and say we
don't want have to pay them a lot we
want the government to set rates we
don't want rates to be adjusted with
inflation we don't all of this right
so the producers and the publishers and
the the songwriters really get hurt with
with this now until today another aspect
of this music music Modernization Act
was that songwriters from who published
works before 1972 would just not be paid
when their music was streamed they just
wouldn't get they just get nothing sorry
too bad and it the whole regime was
really messy this bill is the biggest
change to that since 1909 since the
since the first decade of the 20th
century and it took a lot of political
courage the reason is no senator no
congressman wants to champion the rights
of songwriters like who cares
there's no they're kind of spread out
all over the place LA Nashville a little
bit nobody wants to be their champion
there's no political upside for them to
put their necks out for this it's a
complicated issue you don't want to
upset either record producers or this or
that and it took a lot of political
courage and a lot of songwriters are
saying Democrats were behind the bill
but only this administration could have
gotten it through only a pro-business
Pro market administration would who took
this seriously and was willing to take
the political risk and the moral risk
could have gotten this through and
that's what I've been saying all week
and I've been saying it for a long time
about this administration it has real
moral clarity I don't I'm not saying the
president knows everything about this
law I don't know that he's read this law
probably he hasn't read this law but he
does have this kind of gut instinct it
seems unmoral and political clarity and
I'm glad we can see that and I'm glad
that we could also get that Konya
presser out of it too
we got a lot of mailbag coming up don't
go away but you got to go to Daley wire
comm if you're on Facebook and YouTube
head over there you get me the Andrew
Klavan show the Ben Shapiro show guys
none of this matters this is what
matters if you've if you haven't gotten
your tumblr yet then I'm sorry that
you've drowned may the lord have mercy
on your soul after that kanye presser in
the Oval Office if you have your tumblr
but you
it's filled to the brim you're worried
you know you're worried for your family
and your property and yourself go get
another one go to daily water Tod calm
we'll be right back we're getting
through these today and you can't stop
me you can't stop me
starting with Timothy hey Michael what
is the most recent book that you have
read and what is one person that you or
what is one book that you plan to read
soon thank you you're the man no you're
the man funny you should ask what I'm
doing right now is I'm rereading Dante
rereading the comedy which is the
greatest poem ever written and it's been
nine years since I've read Dante and I
just felt like reading it again nine is
a very important number to Dante and
it's it's just the most tremendous work
of art I've ever encountered so I really
recommend that you read it if you you
can read it in translation there are few
good translations all free and the
internet and if you can if you have
Italian it's much more beautiful in
Italian if you can read it that way and
if you want you can also on the podcast
get a lecture series on the comedy so
you can read along with electro series
coincidentally by the guy who taught me
Dante Josep Aman so uh it's a Yale open
course that's really really good I
highly recommend it and it's in English
it's in translation so you can get that
I think that it was actually recorded
the year I studied with him
coincidentally at 2009 and but now it's
up on podcast so you can go listen to
that too I also just read I was reading
Columbus in the quest for Jerusalem by
Carol Delaney it's a really good book
I've got Gorkhas book we talked about
Gorkhas book yesterday that was a lot of
fun I'm always reading a lot of books at
once so that's what I'm reading what do
I plan to read in the future I don't
know I got to get through Dante first
and then got to get back through you
know that takes a long 200 conti so I'll
get through Dante and then let me know
if you have a good book recommend one to
me from Rodolfo hi Michael my sister and
her female partner recently decided to
have a baby after being together 13
years you need to rush out and call a
scientist you need to call the President
of the United States this is a this is
incredible they have been trying to do
this for all of human history and now
two women have figured out a toe
I have to read more both in their early
30s her partner would be the one to
conceive the baby I opposed her decision
based on the argument that I think it's
deeply selfish to deprive a child of a
father just fulfill their own wants
legally I think they should be able to
do whatever without the law forbidding
them what are your thoughts and how
would I go about to express my
disapproval without getting a knee-jerk
reaction of you think we shouldn't be
allowed to have babies argument that I
expect thanks love the show yes I agree
with you entirely I think it's it's
deeply selfish and wrong to conceive a
baby for the purpose of not letting it
have its father or have its mother
whatever you know I think that's really
really profoundly wrong and they
shouldn't do that there are some options
though you know it we're in a very
complicated regime of invertable in
vitro fertilization or conceiving some
other way you know there is the
old-fashioned way and adoption because
now if single parents can adopt so of
course same-sex couples can adopt it's
very convoluted also the problem with in
vitro fertilization is very often almost
all the time it necessitates the
abortion of embryos or freezing embryos
in perpetuity so you create embryos that
are not are either going to be killed or
not allowed to grow so that's a big
problem in and of itself what your
sisters could do if they want to raise a
child or your sister and her partner if
they want to raise a child that can be a
noble thing I don't think that you
should create a baby begin a baby and
not let it know its father or or have
some strange relationship to its father
but you know you could always your
sister could always adopt especially a
foster child in the United States
there's something like 32 or 36 families
waiting to adopt for every one child but
when it gets up to or for every one
infant but when it gets up to older
children it's much harder there are a
lot of people in the foster system there
are a lot of people in group homes a lot
of people have had to leave bad homes
for bad reasons your sister could adopt
one of them and then I think that would
be real taking a bad situation and
making it making it much better
you're not depriving a child of knowing
its father or knowing its mother that
the
parents have deprived that child of
knowing his parents and you could you
could take a bad situation and make it
better I wouldn't I wouldn't start
though from the premise of condemnation
or of you know yelling at them or
anything like that I it's a perfectly
natural desire to raise a child and it
can be a perfectly good desire but you
don't want a good thing to be turned for
a bad purpose you want to be able to
channel that and make the best of the
situation as you can from Sarah hi
Michael I had a situation recently that
the father of one of my best friends
passed away due to cancer this friend in
her family who I have known and loved
for more than 20 years or vehemently
anti-christian very liberal have always
been because I had so much love and
affection for the man I felt compelled
to somehow convey to him my Christian
thoughts about Jesus dying for our sins
in hope for a deathbed conversion when I
visited however I hesitated at the last
minute and he died the next day I have
felt bad ever since because I missed my
opportunity what would you have done in
this situation very hard situation and I
think a lot of Christians feel this way
when they visit friends or relatives who
are dying and remain atheists or
whatever I don't think that it's
appropriate to you know proselytize at
the very last minute and a very heated
emotional moment saint francis said
preach the gospel and if you must speak
so hopefully some of that christian
charity and virtue and grace is
reflected in your behavior and that your
friends saw that but you know you you
can never know the state of a soul you
can never know the souls relationship to
God Antonin Scalia said before he died
that he doesn't even know if Judas
Iscariot is in Hell you can never know
that you know Christ finds people Christ
comes down the mountain to find people
and then you have your free will to turn
and accept that or not
so I certainly you know maybe I don't
know it's really hard to say what I
would have done in a hypothetical
situation I don't think I would have
gotten up and proselytized
maybe I would have made a couple little
remarks about you know going up to meet
your maker good maker and all of that
but III wouldn't beat yourself up over
it I don't think that would be
appropriate your job is to
select the love of Christ in your
actions and to preach the gospel and you
don't necessarily have to speak from
Thomas dearest st. Michael I wrote you
that's that's very nice it's the feast
of st. Michael a week or two ago I wrote
to you recently about dating these days
despite my 60-plus our work schedule you
recommend online dating or I recommended
it to you I took your advice and boy
howdy I got some dates this past weekend
I went on a second date with a woman
with a PhD in biology we got talking
about social issues it did not go well
she is a female Bernie bro with a white
girls guilty conscience about slavery I
asked some exploratory questions some
how do you define X questions and she
got triggered hardcore I saw a leftist
gathering at the court left his tear
gathering at the corner of her eye but
we hugged it out at the end so here's
the question do I keep dating her hoping
to either flip a communist or do I swipe
left on the leftist and roll the dice
again yours truly Thomas I don't know
she cute yeah you're gay you're getting
things really backwards here buddy I
don't know is she
let's assume she is I the point on this
that you should make it everything you
should really consider is the hardcore
left-wing you know screechie no purple
hat pink hat that girl would never see
you again that girl would not even
entertain she'll probably have stormed
out of the restaurant or you know you
know shrieked in your face so if she
didn't do that there was hope where
there's life there's hope and also look
I have I've supported abortion in my
life I would have called myself agnostic
or atheist
I even had a flirtation with leftism
when I was you know by eighth or ninth
grade something like that people changed
they changed their minds all the time so
there might be hope for her I was
talking I was hanging out with Fleck us
the other day Austin Fletcher you know
Fleck his talks and he had a friend of
his along and she said that she was a
Bernie bro leftist a year ago and now
she's a conservative because someone
opened her eyes so I think that's very
important especially on bio
biological and bioethical issues because
I have the people who are pro-abortion
I think they just don't see the argument
they're seeing all of the science and
they're seeing none of the philosophy
and theology there
seeing all of the physics but none of
the metaphysics so I don't know if she's
cute take her right again if she's not
you know and you're not into it move on
man yeah that's what though this is like
the one advantage of dating apps is that
you can meet a lot of people so but I
don't know I I wouldn't I wouldn't
dismiss an open-minded or curious
left-winger just because she doesn't
check all the boxes of politics we have
time for a couple more from Mellie oh
good day mister opium of the masses
Michael I'm a Catholic in the rise of
anti humanism today is rather
frightening some friends of mine are
advocating for one-child policies and
even going as far as to say that we have
a moral obligation to not have children
anymore how can we fight this neo
Malthusian garbage how can we start
pulling ourselves out of this hole of
anti human narcissism thank you for an
amazing podcast greetings from South
Africa South Africa this is a defining
feature of the left
they hate human life it hates human life
and left us to flirt with leftism you
hate human life to varying degrees the
Communists that Chuck Norris you know
was totally anti human life they talked
about and they want to kill old people
with euthanasia they want to kill babies
with abortion they're just anti human
and it's because they get everything
backwards
they I've heard this from friends of
mine who are environmentalists vegan you
know that whole thing is they say Oh
global warming is so bad it's caused by
people we need less people fewer people
they say you know I'm the humans are bad
for the environment which isn't true by
the way in the history of America since
Western colonization of the Americas the
environment has improved dramatically
the natural environment forests and all
things have been drew dramatically
because the indigenous peoples burned
down whole forests it's a sidebar but
they get it backwards the the the
natural environment is here for us we
have dominion over the land and over the
sea it's here for us we tend it we tend
it as we tend to garden we are stewards
over it but it's for us don't get it
backwards this is a difference between
environmentalism and conservationism
environmentalists say that we need to
protect the environment because it has
rights and it's so beautiful in its
mother Gaia
conservationists say we need to protect
the environment so that we can enjoy it
some more you know they say we need to
we need to protect the deer so that we
can keep shooting the deer and that's a
much more balanced perspective so I
think that I think one way is to mock it
because it's not that environmentalism
doesn't have a good point it's just that
it gets everything out of balance it has
no sense of humor it has no sense of the
natural balance of the world which is
true so much in leftism
and when something has it doesn't have a
sense of humor you should laugh at it
and hopefully it will restore a little
balanced we have time for one more one
more I don't care what you say from
Christopher with Columbus Day I mean
indigenous peoples day over I rewatched
your Columbus Day special which talks
about how he was a great man however I
also saw the Adam ruins everything
episode about Christopher Columbus and
he starts off calling him an incompetent
buffoon he does back up what he says
with sources but you can't both be right
about Columbus with two diametrically
different points of view on the same
person how are we supposed to
distinguish who was right and who was
wrong big fan of the show thanks Chris
oh I'm right does that clear it up I'm
right I don't know who Adam ruins
everything is and I have never seen it
but I do know a lot about Christopher
Columbus if this guy is saying that he
was an incompetent buffoon I'll just
I'll just throw out some factoids that
maybe could dispel that he discovered
the Americas from Europe he discovered
the new world he was the greatest
Navigator of his age he made it across
the ocean sea using mostly dead
reckoning he didn't even have an
astrolabe on his first voyage and yet he
made it down how did he know he sensed
when he was on Porto Santo when he was
in Portugal he could feel and he would
take all of these incredible voyages up
to the Brittain up to even past Britain
up into the Arctic and he could feel the
easterly currents in the northern
Atlantic so he just suspected it was as
far as I can tell the first guy to
suspect that there might be a westerly
current if you went a little further
down south so he decided that he would
say a little bit a little bit further
south certainly felt that westerly
current and he took it all the way over
to the Americas he was also brilliantly
educated beyond just his
his navigational skills which were
unparalleled in his time the evidence of
that of course there was a lot of
evidence of that one of which is he
discovered the Americas but also he was
devoted to reading the Bible at a time
when a lot of people didn't read the
Bible because either they were
illiterate and Christopher Columbus
certainly was illiterate
and in many ways self-taught but he made
sure education was very important to him
but he read the Bible devotedly I think
it was he was with Franciscan monks and
he would read it all of the time because
he was trying to figure out the age
since the since the first man he was
trying to figure out when predictions of
the Apocalypse would happen he was
trying to figure out I had to make sense
of all geopolitics the fall of
Constantinople and so he would read that
very well he spoke a number of languages
Italian Spanish obviously he was
determined and he knew exactly how to
play the Portuguese and the Spanish he
was he was kicked out it was ultimately
rejected from the Spanish crown to fund
his voyage and at the very last minute
they called him back and his biographers
his contemporary and early biographers
suggest that the reason he was called
back is because of the sheer force of
his personality and the brilliance of
his whip so that's just a little taste
just a little taste
but whoever this Adam person is has no
idea what he's talking about that's our
show I wish we could get two more but we
can't make sure that you tune in
tomorrow I think another Kingdom is
being released for everybody if you're a
subscriber you can already see another
Kingdom right now on the website and it
is really cool you know my job in
another Kingdom is to read the book so I
got the I got the best job but the story
is incredible and the artwork is really
really good that you know that we now
have visual production so they're sets
there's artwork it's really cool it's
awesome so check it out at at daily
wire.com or you can watch part of it
tomorrow and listen to the whole thing
otherwise have a good weekend I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael nul
show I'll see you on Monday
[Music]
the michael noland is produced by semia
Villarreal executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by Mike Gore Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua L Vera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018